[Applause]
this Warehouse destroyed early Monday in
a Russian airstrike on Odessa all of the
humanitarian Aid inside the 1 000 square
meter building gone to the Red Cross
says no workers were inside the facility
at the time but given the destruction
some projects in the area have been
suspended a series of Russian strikes
rained down on several regions including
Odessa harkiv mikalayov Hassan and Kiev
at one point Monday the entire country
was blanketed by an attack Alert warning
I heard a loud explosions as this 76
year old woman when asked what she did
she replied there was nothing I could do
I sheltered in the corridor behind two
walls vitelli Klitschko says Russia sent
36 Kamikaze drones to the capital but
all were destroyed by the air defense
system five people was taking injuries
uh two people right now in hospitals but
nobody has died it's very important the
attacks come as Ukraine and Europe
celebrate victory over Nazi Germany in
the end of the second world war in
Russia Victory celebrations happen on
May 9th the Kremlin had been pushing for
success in the East to highlight during
their festivities last year ukrainians
were told to take Extra Care on the 8th
and 9th fearing an onslaught of attacks
from Russia this year A reversal of
rolls several Russian cities have
canceled or scaled back Soviet Victory
Day saying they could be targeted by
pro-ukrainian saboteurs
it's unclear if that is the result of an
explosion last week at the Kremlin which
Moscow claims was a Ukrainian attempt on
the president's life or because so many
Russian soldiers have been killed and
weapons destroyed that a big military
parade just as impossible this year
Crystal gemancing Global News London